Raquel Levis files a restraining order
against Sheena Shea E.T has confirmed
that Raquel filed to seek a
court-ordered protection from her
Vanderpump Rules co-star on Tuesday
following an alleged altercation between
them the filing comes amid the Fallout
from arkell's affair with Tom Sandoval
who has been in a relationship with
their fellow co-star Ariana Maddox for
the last nine years something I realized
especially with being with Ariana most
is that if you have respect for the
other person you respect their
intelligence their opinion their views
everything that really makes a huge
difference
it keeps you from you know in
relationships you see when people go to
the dark side the alleged altercation
between Raquel and Sheena reportedly
went down after the two appeared on
Watch What Happens Live last week where
Raquel addressed her controversial kiss
with the other Tom Tom Schwartz I'm just
trying to live my life and I'm sorry if
that offends people but it's not going
to stop me from doing what I want to do
a source told people that after the
taping Raquel came clean to Sheena about
her affair with Sandoval Sheena was
reportedly Furious and that's when
things allegedly got physical E.T has
reached out to Sheena for comment Ariana
reportedly learned of the affair by
discovering an intimate video of Raquel
on Sandoval's phone Raquel claims it was
recorded without her consent and on
Tuesday she sent several members of the
cast including Sandoval a legal warning
to delete it Raquel
tell your little Mickey Mouse lawyer
that if he has stuff to send over he can
send things to my lawyer same with the
rest of my friends and cast alright Lala
Kent called out Raquel in a since
deleted post to Instagram Tuesday I've
never in my life had a lawyer
contact me in my personal email all
right I don't know if you know how this
works I know you're pretty brand new to
the game didn't last long and later in
the day she addressed the drama during a
live stream we want the skin of all tea
when will Tom apologize to Ariana I am
not in Tom's head I don't know what he's
thinking never liked that guy and now it
feels good to have everyone else feel
the same way I do well on Wednesday
Sandoval shared a personal message on
Instagram apologizing to everyone he's
hurt most of all I want to apologize to
Ariana I made mistakes I was selfish and
made Reckless decisions that hurt
somebody I love shortly after that
Raquel shared her own statement
exclusively with E.T writing in part
there is no excuse I am not a victim and
I must own my actions and I deeply
regret hurting Ariana
[Music]
thank you